we have welcome to this video a new five
minutes blitz game on the ICC let's see
young Queens gambit don't count the
Albans all right yeah I'll take it upon
us upon and in case of the album's it's
very often that it's just a pawn um okay
Bishop e6 hmm I'm not sure what what do
you play here III probably a 3some one
of the best lines against them the
Albans but I'm not sure III maybe before
was also an option mmm no okay but for
now while I'm still has the extra plan
blacks got chances to to get it back
with 96 and takes you five but um it's
not clear that this really equalizes
okay but some continue to develop he
also could have gone light f5 and also a
possibility so just how to continue yeah
he will learn get this bag might be five
the smooth i need to a constructed which
scenario form for the forgiving the pawn
back maybe this one the idea being if he
if he takes twice a plane I'd be five
attacking c7 if he goes rook t7 I Bishop
f4 and he's got problems with the c7
porn
so the idea of this is to actually
return the pawn and trying to get some
position alarm I'm advantages in return
okay he prevented this so how to how to
proceed ninety-five as a possibility
they takes twice of God Bishop c4 the
antis should be it should be really good
but it can go look t7 and then i'm not
sure what 95 is this really is really
accomplishing I'm maybe night after this
could be an IBM try that to watch him
for too far behind on the clock this
idea now I take me six enzyme if he
exchanges on a 40 actually allows me to
take only six this leads to a very
one-sided position with the two bishops
and um this is weakness but it's got 93
which M looks like it simplifies to
black them a benefit my G formats a
possible the team some mmm should I'm
right it's hard to keep the bishops
actually maybe it's not so bad firm as I
initially thought okay let's let's keep
it simple if you place 93 you lose a
couple of 10pm time I'm still I'm still
on better because of the six pawn it is
some it is very very slight of course
it's not substantial edge should be too
okay yeah okay this is very very little
gentle not much choice I need to even
exchanged looks yeah he's only got to
this small weakness only successor
should be a draw but up him I can try on
found a little bit hmm that's what
question is if I go Bishop b5 I go
should be five the song at least puts a
question to him do you want to exchange
it's probably a draw in any case but i'm
not sure if he wants a wants to allow me
to take ok now i can think okay now
don't want okay yeah i would now with
g45 i might be able to create an app ass
porn here what is he doing I'm playing
age 45 and I'm just promoting he needs
to have a king to stop the pawns
I mean you cannot go King b6f a five or
something this is by far too slow I
think it is not even able to stop it
anymore I mean not in a decent way at
least ok so just King before I need to
do this first maybe maybe he's got time
maybe he's got a five guys he's got a
five hmm is this what is winning yeah I
need to go here to have some chance when
I'm is check now the problem is i can i
can get to d5 and takes d5 the the
policy is not quick enough and cng porn
should win
check check check black resign yeah he
he's really stumbled in this in the sand
game but i'm not i'm not sure if if it
is really winning it should be winning
maybe here completely d4c hi if this is
this is the one yeah yeah of course i
need to play i need to go here just to
shun I thought actually that just
creating the pawn would be enough but
probably this is not the case this is
just better he's got no no diff defense
ready let's say some my other system
goes let's see here I go here and always
attack the spawn a tie him to the pawn
and I can just um try to create a passed
pawn here and he has no way way to stop
that it's even a matter of Tempe is his
basically in soups one if he moves the
king I win here or here and let's say
something like this he doesn't he
doesn't even have a movie 5 f3 and now
it's oops wrong I don't even need a
passport the King position is winning
what I did I mean okay this is of course
really weird going to be seven
I think I'm actually what I did should
win as well yeah that is probably
winning but this always needs a really
accurate calculation this is winning
it's clear but maybe he can do something
else but I don't think so really I'm
breaking through on the fifth rank and
i'll probably get older I mean let's
look at just something like this here
this is probably relatively easy just
get the porn yeah well um he of course
doesn't need to UM here does this kind
of move you can you should place a move
to a wide the bishop trade to just to
keep it simple and they'll say let's say
g6 or something and then you can easily
retreat the bishop then there's nothing
happening alright thanks for watching